as a leader of any organization you
struggle with getting your people to
want to be more driven right today i'm
going to talk about how to get the
person who is
content and lazy to be extremely
competitive and hard working
i'm patrick bedeville host of
valuetainment weekly and you know a lot
of times as
leaders we tend to forget how terrible
we were at one point right we tend to
forget
how lazy we were at one point or how
lack of discipline we had or maybe we
lacked competitive
or driving there was somebody in our
life that kind of injected that thing in
us to
to to to want to go out and compete and
and have a strong work ethic and
what i've learned over the years of
having coach tens of thousands of people
is there's literally four different
levels everybody falls under okay
lowest level of person okay they are
extremely content
and they're extremely lazy so it's a
content
lazy person so what do you do with
somebody who is content
and lazy well normally there's not a lot
of stuff you can do for that person
what usually ends up happening for them
no matter how many books and stuff you
give them
they tend to stay content and lazy you
wonder why
majority of the time this is 99 of the
time
a life-changing event changes their
habits
either a girl breaks up with them either
they lose everything they have
either they go into debt either somebody
passes away
something dramatically happens in their
lives where
boom they wake up it happens to
everybody it's happened to all of us at
one point right
so then the third level of person you
could be working with in the
organization somebody that's
very competitive i'm talking about
they're super competitive
but very lazy okay this is somebody that
every time you give an initiative and
you
talk about one person or you give
recognition to this one person they are
going nuts but they don't take action so
you're glad on one side because they're
so competitive but you're upset on the
other side why are they so content so
what do you do with this person here
what this person normally needs this
person what they normally need
they need to make a decision already and
two
they need to have a lot of urgency in
their lives knowing they don't have a
lot of time left those are two things
the person who's competitive and lazy
needs the third level is somebody that's
content they're not really that
competitive they're totally content
but they're the hardest working people
you have in your group isn't that
sometimes confusing where you're like
this person is so content they're always
happy they're just but they work too
hard they show up early they leave late
but they're very content why are they
working so hard you know what that
person needs you know what that person
needs
here's what that person needs that
person needs a
bigger environment they need an
environment to be able to compete
and see other people and how they're
doing it on all that stuff so sometimes
they simply need a shift in an
environment and
the second thing they need is they need
to start feeding their minds with more
books and biographies on thinking
bigger doing bigger normally they're
thinking too small because they're
content
they need to start thinking bigger and
normally that environment will do that
for them and last but not least your
favorite kind of people you'd love to
have in your organization this is what
makes
any organization a winning organization
it's competitive
and hard working competitive and
hard-working so someone might say well
they really don't need anything right no
no no no these guys
definitely need things and what is it
number one they need to be recognized
for their efforts
they need to be recognized for their
efforts and
they need new challenges because if they
themselves don't sit down after they get
i'm gonna do this boom they go get it
i'm gonna go achieve this i'm gonna go
get it
if they don't themselves take a time out
and say
what are my next three things i want to
go get maybe it's a hundred thousand
dollars in savings maybe it's a million
dollars in savings maybe it's
a car a house maybe it's a vacation
maybe it's a money to charity maybe it's
something they want to do for their
mother their father maybe it's a new
milestone in business in life
if they don't have new challenges in
place they can at any point go from
level number one which is competitive
and hard working
to level number two which is content and
hard working because they've achieved
their milestone
so you need to look at this level these
four different levels here
want to identify where you rank yourself
and two put your top five best people on
that list
and know what they need and give them
that give them that
equip them with the values that they
need for them to work on in order for
them to get to the next level
it's your job as a leader to do that if
you want to advance your organization
it's my message of the week please click
on the link to go to my website
patrickbetdavid.com and be sure to
subscribe to our weekly newsletter